This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all?
这是一个iHeart播客。保证源自真人。在为孩子们准备午餐的每一个夜晚背后，其实都充满了悬念。他们最后会吃蔬菜吗？面食能挺过第一口吗？午餐盒带回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？
And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here.
又或者，在切完黄瓜之前，你能看完第8集吗？选择Bell纯光纤网络，尊享Netflix和Disney Plus，每月仅需94加元起。签订两年期互联网合约并开通自动扣款，价格两年保持不变。访问bell.ca了解详情并查询覆盖情况。Bell，连接意味着一切。嗨，Portlandia的粉丝们。我是卡莉·布朗斯坦（Carrie Brownstein）和弗莱德·阿米森（Fred Armisen）。
The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, A.O. Rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysell, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more.
90年代的梦想在播客中依然生动。我们正在推出《波特兰尼亚重温》（Podlandia, A.O. Rewatch），这是一个全新的播客节目，我们将一起重温《波特兰尼亚》的每一集，剖析搞笑短剧，深入探讨我们标志性的角色，并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后故事。同时，将帮助我们将其变为现实的人们也会加入我们。包括客串明星、合作伙伴和朋友，其中包括导演乔纳森·克里塞尔（Jonathan Krisel）、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦（Kyle MacLachlan）、传奇音乐家艾米·曼（Amy Mann）等等。
Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport.
凯尔在这里全力以赴。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌。嗯，我以为你们所有人都要写首歌。我记得你是这么想的。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《波特兰尼亚重温》（Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch）。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。
And Sean Clements. We host the podcast Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our guests improve their careers by mainly focusing on how they can help us improve our careers. The show is famously super accessible so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes and understand what's going on. We recommend some of our recent episodes
我是肖恩·克莱门斯（Sean Clements）。我们是播客《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）的主持人。在每一集中，我们都试图帮助我们的嘉宾改善他们的职业生涯，主要是通过关注他们如何能帮助我们改善我们的职业生涯。这个节目以超级易懂著称，所以你可以轻松跳入我们的650集节目中的任何一集，并听懂在讲什么。我们推荐一些我们最近的节目
with Ben Stiller, Danny McBride, Riz Ahmed, and Mary Steenbergin. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. Your duolingo is not going to come back to you when a man is inside.
嘉宾包括本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller）、丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride）、里兹·阿 Ahmed（Riz Ahmed）和玛丽·斯滕伯根（Mary Steenburgen）。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）。在《Solita》中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。当一个男人在
of you. Oh no. I'm Julie Pinheiro and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nick Titoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lease Black Klansman. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Titoro, I deliver a pizza to a new guest. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt? To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness,
你体内时，你的多邻国（Duolingo）可帮不了你。哦，不。我是朱莉·皮涅罗（Julie Pinheiro），我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕有的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就能说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代同情。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。我是尼克·图图罗（Nick Turturro）。你可能从《纽约重案组》（NYPD Blue）、《最长的一码》（The Longest Yard）或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》（Black Klansman）中认识我。在我的新播客《与尼克·图图罗一起传递快乐》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Turturro）中，我给一位新嘉宾送去一个披萨。我和每个人分享了一片披萨，从赛斯·罗林斯（Seth Rollins）。你在对我的金腰带做什么？到比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr）。我觉得我从来没见过哪个人的精神状态像我一样这么出格。现在，我们还将迎来更多优秀的嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·图图罗（John Turturro）。这节目叫快乐，
delivering happiness. And many, many more. Open your free high heart radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Tutro. And listen now. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Nervous system regulation is probably something we have all heard more about, I would say, in recent years. It's this idea, if you haven't heard about it,
传递快乐。还有许许多多精彩内容。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《与尼克·图图罗一起传递快乐》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Turturro）。并立即收听。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克（Gemma Speike），欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十多岁时最大变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。非常高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目，当然，我们将剖析二十多岁时的心理学。神经系统调节可能是我们近年来听到更多的概念，我想这么说。这是一个理念，如果你还没听说过的话，
that a great deal of our stress, our irritation, our inability to focus comes from an invisible kind of dysregulation within our brain and our body that we are no longer sensitive to. Our settings have kind of been changed at the switch internally. And the consequence of this is a nervous system that doesn't necessarily work and a body and a mind that had stopped feeling like our own in many ways. As with many other concepts in psychology, nervous system regulation has definitely moved from something that was only really spoken about in a couple of textbooks, in therapy rooms, in trauma-informed care, to something we hear about in wellness podcasts, including this one, but wellness spaces in TikToks, online, in workout classes, wherever you've
我们的很多压力、烦躁、注意力不集中，都来自于我们大脑和身体内部一种无形的发育失调，而我们对此已经不再敏感。我们的内在开关不知何时被更改了。而这带来的后果就是一个不一定能正常运作的神经系统，以及一个在许多方面不再感觉像是我们自己的身体和心灵。正如心理学中的许多其他概念一样，神经系统调节绝对已经从一个只在少数教科书、治疗室、创伤知情护理中被讨论的概念，变成了我们在健康播客（包括本播客）、TikTok等健康空间、网络、健身课程中都能听到的内容，无论你在哪里体验过健康，我们现在都非常非常经常听到关于神经系统调节的讨论。这是件坏事吗？绝对不是。我不这么认为。但对于如此重要的事，你确实要确保自己拥有正确的事实和所需的科学知识。你知道，在许多方面，你的神经系统构成了你是谁的核心。它进而决定了你的行为方式、你是否能成为一个好的朋友、好的伴侣，
experienced wellness, we hear about nervous system regulation very, very regularly now. Is that a bad thing? Absolutely not. I don't think so. But for something so critical, you do want to make sure that you have the right facts and you have the scientific knowledge that is required. You know, your nervous system sits at the core of who you are in so many ways. It goes on to determine how you behave, whether you can be a good friend, a good partner,
以及你自我拓展和成长的能力。所以今天我们要讨论的是基础知识，以及当你的神经系统出问题时到底会发生什么，如何解决它，如何察觉失调。以及你需要做哪些事情才能让自己从失调的状态调整到调节状态，这其中究竟涉及什么，因为网上可能会听到很多事情，或者对此以及压力的价值或作用存在很多可能并不准确的误解。闲话少说，让我们进入神经系统调节的心理学。所以，如果你听到有人说，你知道，
your capacity for self-expansion and growth. And so today we're going to talk about the basics and what actually happens when something goes wrong with your nervous system, how to fix it, how to notice dysregulation. and the things that are necessary for you to take yourself from a place of dysregulation to regulation and what that actually involves because there are a lot of things that you may hear online or a lot of misconceptions about this and about the value or the role of stress that might not be accurate. So without further ado, let us get into the psychology of nervous system regulation. So if you were to hear someone say, you know,
“我现在正在努力调节我的神经系统。”他们在切实意义上到底是什么意思呢？当人们谈论神经系统调节时，他们通常是在谈论身体在不同唤醒状态之间灵活转换的能力。这里的关键词是“灵活”。神经系统调节有时被呈现得好像你的身体是一台坏了的机器，需要被黑客入侵、重置、排毒、用冰敷来强行服从。它需要被优化成一种永久的平静状态。这并不是神经系统调节的意义所在。当神经系统能够被提醒、能够感到压力、能够被激活，但同时也能从这些状态中平静下来时，它的运作效果才是最好的。现在有一点，嗯，必须要知道的是，我们的身体并不只有这两种设置。
I'm really working on regulating my nervous system right now. What would they actually mean by that in a tangible sense? When people talk about nervous system regulation, they are usually talking about the body's ability to move flexibly between different states of arousal. And the key word here is flexibly. nervous system regulation is sometimes presented as if your body is a broken machine and it needs to be hacked, reset, detoxed, iced into submission. It needs to be optimized into a permanent state of calm. That is not what nervous system regulation is about. The nervous system functions best when it can be alerted, it can be stressed, it can be fired up, but it can also come down from that. Now something that, well, something essential to know is that our body also doesn't just have these two settings.
你并非不是处于压力中就是处于平静中。你的身体实际上有三种状态，尤其是你的神经系统有三种状态。第一种是腹侧迷走神经状态。这与安全感、连接感、社交参与感、脚踏实地的感觉有关。在这种状态下，我们可以进行交流，我们感到与他人有联系，我们感到与他人有联系，我们感到与自己有联系。我们可以调节自己的情绪。我们感到自己身心俱在。这通常是我们力求返回的状态。我们可以处于的第二种状态是交感神经状态。这与动员、战斗或逃跑有关。身体为行动做准备。
You are not either stressed or calm. Your body actually has three states and your nervous system in particular has three states. The first is the ventral vagal state. This is associated with feelings of safety, connection, social engagement, groundedness. In this state, we can communicate, we feel connected to others, we feel connected to others, we feel connected to ourselves. We can regulate our emotions. We feel present in our bodies, in our mind. This is the state we are usually aiming to return to. The second kind of state that we can be in is the sympathetic state. This is associated with mobilization, fight or flight. The body prepares for action.
这正是这种状态真正代表的含义。我们感到焦虑。我们感到愤怒、焦躁不安、紧迫感、恐慌、高度警惕，我们处于保护模式。第三种是背侧迷走神经状态。现在这与完全的失去行动能力、关闭有关。你感到麻木。你感到解离。你感觉情绪上与外界断开连接。在你和世界其他地方之间存在着这样一层过滤网。这种情况通常发生在神经系统感知到战斗、逃跑或迎合是不可能的时候，于是它转入节能和退缩模式。另一个常见的误解是，我们应该以始终处于第一种状态——即腹侧迷走神经状态为目标。但我们的神经系统拥有这三种不同的状态是有原因的，即使它们很不方便或者有时很痛苦。它们
This is what this state really represents. We feel anxious. We feel angry, restless, urgent, panic, hyper alert, we are in protection mode. The third is the dorsal vagal state. Now this is associated with complete immobilization, with shutdown. You feel numb. You feel disassociated. You feel emotionally disconnected. There is this filter between you and the rest of the world. And it often happens when the nervous system perceives that fighting or fleeing or fawning is not possible, so it moves into conservation and withdrawal. A common misconception, again, is that we should aim to be in the first state, that ventral, vagal state at all times. But our nervous system has these three different states for a reason, even if they are inconvenient or sometimes painful. They
各自都有其目的。有时你需要被激活。你需要肾上腺素。你需要远离危险。而且——这听起来可能会很奇怪——当情况过于严重时，你实际上可能需要关闭自己并在情感上抽离。有些事件对我们的大脑、灵魂和身体来说实在太宏大了，以至于无法面对。而在那些时刻，身体抽离的倾向或能力是强大且能救命的。当然，如果你在那个时刻活了下来，且你的创伤依然未得到平复，这会产生长期后果；但能够在那个时刻抽离、能够进入那种状态并降低强度是很重要的。我应该说，另一件要说的事是，一个经过调节的神经系统也是从逻辑角度运作的。例如，如果有什么东西吓到我了，
each serve a purpose. Sometimes you need activation. You need adrenaline. You need to get away from danger. You also, and this is going to sound strange, might actually need to shut down and remove yourself emotionally when a situation is too much. There are just some events that are too big for our brain and our soul and our body to face. And our body's inclination or ability to disengage in those moments is powerful and is life-saving. Of course, that has long-term consequences if you survive that moment and if your trauma remains undisturbed, but being able to disengage, being able to get into that state in that moment and reduce the intensity is important. I should say the other thing is that a regulated nervous system also operates from a logical place. For example, if something scares me,
我应该对它保持警惕。但如果发生了一些微小且微不足道的事情，我不应该对它做出与面对危险、面对威胁时相同的反应。这就是我们看到失调发生的地方。我们的神经系统表现得不理智。你的大脑和中枢神经系统无法分辨积极、中立和消极的区别。一切感觉都一样。感觉就像是一个威胁，因此反应变得不再是它应该有的样子。要理解神经系统调节，我们还需要理解。一个非常核心的概念，那就是我们的耐受窗口。这是一个由加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）的精神病学家丹·西格尔（Dan Siegel）博士在20世纪90年代提出的理论。本质上，他所说的是，我们的耐受窗口
I should be alert to that. But if something small and insignificant happens, I should not be having the same response to that as I did to the danger, as I did to the threat. This is the point where we see dysregulation. Our nervous system is behaving irrationally. Your brain and your central nervous system can't tell the difference between positive, neutral, and negative. Everything just feels the same. It feels like it is a threat and so the response becomes not as it should be. To understand nervous system regulation, we also need to understand. a very core concept, which is our window of tolerance. This is a theory that was coined by the psychiatrist Dr. Dan Siegel from UCLA in the 1990s. And essentially what he said is that our window
就是我们能够运作、能够感知、能够对生活做出反应而又不会彻底崩溃或彻底关闭的区域。当我们处于耐受窗口内部时，我们可能仍然会感到压力。我们可能仍然会感到悲伤、nervous（紧张）甚至兴奋，但这些感觉是可控的。我想，我们几乎可以与这些感觉进行某种对话，如果这说得通的话。就像我们可以为它们保留空间一样。我知道这是一个被过度使用的词，但没错，我们可以为它们保留空间。当我们的神经系统不堪重负时，我们就会移出这个窗口。而我们移出这个窗口的方向有两个方向之一。而这些方向与我们刚才谈到的背侧迷走神经状态和交感神经状态有关。
of tolerance is the zone where we can function, we can feel, we can respond to life without becoming completely overwhelmed or completely shut down. When we are inside our window of tolerance, we might still feel stressed. We might still feel sad or nervous or even excited, but those feelings feel manageable. We can almost have, I guess, a conversation with those feelings, if that makes sense. Like we can kind of hold space for them. I know that's such an overused term, but yeah, we can hold space for them. When our nervous system becomes overwhelmed, we move outside of that window. And we move outside of that window in one of two directions. and these directions relate to the dorsal vagal state and the sympathetic state that we just spoke about.
我们的神经系统可以移动的第一个方向是朝向过度唤醒。这也就是我们经常与战斗或逃跑反应联系在一起的现象。这是身体进入行动点的过程。这是你的身体通过激活心率做出反应。你的身体会有麻刺感，你的呼吸开始显得不那么自然，你的思绪可能会狂飙。这就是过度唤醒。第二种是低度唤醒。这更多地与我们之前谈到的冻结、关闭、崩溃有关。你可能不会感到亢奋和被激活，而是会感到麻木、思维模糊和抽离。有时，就像，无法真正思考，
The first direction that our nervous system can move in is towards hyperarousal. This is what we often associate again with that fight or flight response. It is the body moving into a point of action. It is your body responding with activating your heart rate. Your body gets tingly, your breathing starts to feel less natural, your thoughts might race. that is hyper arousal. The second is hypo arousal. This is more associated with the freeze, with the shutdown, with the collapse that we spoke about before. Instead of feeling wired and activated, you might feel numb and foggy and detached. And sometimes, like, unable to really think,
无法真正说话。一切都开始变慢。低度唤醒基本上就是身体在退场，并说正在发生的所有其他事情都太多了。我无法战斗，我也无法逃跑，因为我在物理意义上、情感意义上、心理意义上已经这样做了太久，以至于我只需要保存能量并熬过这一切。而且进入过度唤醒状态对我也已经不再适用了。这不是软弱，也不是懒惰，它和前一种一样，和战斗或逃跑反应一样，都是一种生存反应。究竟是什么决定了你会进入过度唤醒还是低度唤醒状态，其实有点难以
unable to really speak. Everything just starts to take a while. Hypo arousal is the body basically checking out and saying all of this other stuff that is going on is too much. I cannot fight, I cannot run, because I've been doing that for so long in a physical sense, in an emotional sense, in a psychological sense, that I just need to conserve energy and just survive this. And getting into the hyperarousal state is no longer accessible to me. This is not weakness, it's not laziness, it is just as much a survival response as the previous kind, as. as the fight or flight response. What determines whether you're going to go into hyper or hypo arousal is somewhat difficult
弄明白。这是压力或创伤的水平、压力或创伤的类型、压力或创伤的频率，以及这种情况持续了多久的组合。但是，你可以在耐受窗口之外停留很长时间，特别是在你处于低度唤醒状态时。这在以下情况下最为明显，我不知道，我不知道，如果你经历过这些时刻，或者你见过这样的人，他们就是不在乎。他们不在乎到底发生了什么。就像，几乎有一种无所谓的心态。对此有很多词汇，我认为最好的一种是，这是一种长期解离
to figure out. It's a combination of the level of stress or trauma, the type of stress or trauma, the frequency of stress or trauma, and how long it's been going on for. But you can sit outside your window for tolerance for a long time, specifically if you are in a hypo aroused state. This is most evident when, I don't know, I don't know, if you've had these moments or you've seen people who are like this where they just don't care. They don't care what really happens. Like, there is almost a sense of just ambivalence. There are so many words for it, I think the best one is like, it's a state of prolonged dissociation
或抑郁或背侧迷走神经关闭的状态。本质上，我们的身体。就像是在说，这太难以承受了，我需要不再以我一直以来经历的方式去体验这一切。正如我所说，这种情况可以持续很长时间。过度唤醒也可以持续很长时间，但你更有可能在某些时候脱离它并进入过度唤醒状态。那么，无论我们最终走向哪个方向，到底是什么让神经系统失调的呢？我将重点关注导致失调的三个大方向。首先是未处理的创伤。我认为我们需要更多地将创伤视为一种神经系统疾病或神经系统损伤。正如一场事故可以把骨头折断成两半，或者一种疾病会影响你的
or depression or dorsal vagal shutdown. Essentially, our body. has been like, this is too much to bear, I need to just not be able to experience this the way that I've been experiencing it. And as I said, this can go on for a long time. Hyper arousal can also go on for a long time, but it is more likely that at times you will come out of it into the hyperarousal state. So what actually makes the nervous system dysregulated, whatever direction we end up going in? I would focus on three broad routes to dysregulation. The first is unprocessed trauma. I think we need to talk about trauma more as a nervous system disease or a nervous system injury. Just as an accident can snap a bone in half or a disease can impact how your
器官运作一样，创伤会在生理上损害你的神经系统。当你遭遇创伤时，把它想象成有一堵巨大的混凝土墙，你推之不动，也无法理解。所以你的身体和大脑只能不断地向它撞击，不断地试图把这堵墙移开，不断地试图穿过它，最终弄得浑身是血、青紫交加且无法运作。当创伤保持未处理状态时，神经系统就会受损，并且它会变得对任何类似于最初威胁的事物更加敏感。这就是我们最终产生触发点的地方。你知道，你男朋友在玩电子游戏时因为兴奋而提高嗓门，在你看来并不是“哦，他只是因为和哥们聊天而兴奋”。在你看来，这是“他疯了，他在生气”。这感觉就像我小时候我父亲在大喊大叫，我们需要关闭自己，我们需要离开这里。
organs function, trauma damages your nervous system physically. When you encounter trauma, think of it as if there is this huge concrete wall that you can't push through, you can't make sense of. So your body and your brain just keeps throwing itself at it, keeps trying to move this wall out of its way, just keeps trying to get through it and ends up bloodied and bruised and unable to function. When trauma remains unprocessed, the nervous system is injured and it can become more sensitive to anything that resembles the original threat. This is where we end up developing triggers. You know, your boyfriend raising his voice in excitement at a video game doesn't register to you as, oh, he's just excited because he's talking with his mates. It registers as he is mad, he is angry. This feels like when I was a kid and my father was yelling and we need to shut down and we need to get out of here.
尽管这两种情况完全不同。一个对你生气的朋并不是仅仅是一个对你生气的朋，或者一个需要解决的社交问题。它代表着一段关系的失去，被拒绝、冲突、被抛弃的可能，并且它会引发你身上所有来自过去经验的反应。2006年发表在《临床神经科学对话》（Dialogues in Clinical Neuroscience）杂志上的一篇综述指出，创伤性应激与大脑回路的变化有关，特别是涉及杏仁核、海马体和内侧前额叶皮层。其中的海马体在这里尤为重要，
Even though those two situations are completely different. A friend who was upset at you isn't just a friend that's upset at you or a social problem to work through. It represents the loss of a relationship, the potential for rejection, for conflict, for abandonment and it triggers all these reactions on you that have come from past experiences. There was a 2006 review published in dialogues in clinical neuroscience, the journal, and it describes how traumatic stress is associated with changes in your brain circuits, specifically involving the amygdala, the hippocampus, and the medial prefrontal cortex. The hippocampus in particular is important here,
因为它有助于将记忆置于时间和背景中。当你的海马体无法再正确做到这一点时，它就会陷入挣扎。它极力挣扎，难以将某些经历归档为“这发生在当时”与“这发生在现在”。无论它经历什么，界限都变得模糊了，你可以看出为什么这会变得非常成问题。2012年的另一项元分析也发现，如果你经历过创伤，我们会看到改变了的神经活动的持续模式。包括他们提到的海马体、杏仁核等区域，还有威胁处理和情绪调节区域。我们在生理上看到了这一点，这支持了这样一种观点，即创伤会使大脑对危险的提醒更加敏感，即使你已经不在那个最初的
because it is what helps place memories in time and in context. When your hippocampus stops being able to do that correctly, it struggles. It struggles so dearly to file certain experiences as this happened then versus this is happening now. Anything it experiences, the lions get blurred, and you can see why that becomes really problematic. Another meta-analysis done in 2012 also found, if you experience trauma, we see consistent patterns of altered neural activity. including in areas like they said in the hippocampus, the amygdala, but also in threat processing and emotional regulation. We see this physically and this supports the idea that trauma can leave the brain more reactive to reminders of danger, even when you are no longer in that original
情境中了。一种气味、一种语调、你知道的，一种奇怪的身体感觉都可能引发全身的应激反应，因为神经系统正试图根据它从过去经验中学到的东西，以及它被创伤塑造和伤害的方式来保护你。现在，导致神经系统调节的第二个途径要微妙得多，也更具慢性特征，我们将在稍事休息后讨论这一点，以及我们的小事是如何导致神经系统失调的。我喜欢吃得好。但在下班后、跑完腿、做完其他所有事情之后，做饭根本是不可能的。这就是为什么我开始使用Factor。
situation. A smell, a tone of voice, you know, a strange bodily sensation can trigger a full body stress response because the nervous system is trying to protect you based on what it has learned from past experiences and based on the way it's been shaped and injured by trauma. Now the second route to nervous system regulation is a bit more subtle and it's more chronic and we're going to talk about that and how our nervous system gets dysregulated by small things even after this short break. I like to eat well. But after work, after errands, after everything else, cooking just doesn't happen. That's why I started using Factor.
Factor提供新鲜、从未冷冻、即食的餐食。由营养学家设计，实现均衡营养，真正适合我的生活。无需备菜，无需清理。只需加热、享用，然后继续。就这样，我找回了自己的时间。没有盘子，没有糟糕的选择，没有晚餐压力。我不需要做计划。不知怎的，我依然在吃着像
Factor delivers fresh, never frozen, ready to eat meals. Designed by dietitians for balanced nutrition that actually fits my life. No prep, no cleanup. Just heat, eat, and move on. And just like that, I get my time back. No dishes, no poor choices, no dinner stress. I don't have to plan. And somehow, I'm still eating meals.
烤三文鱼、奶油虾仁意面和风味鸡肉碗这样的饭菜。尝起来就像是我花了一番功夫做出来的食物，尽管，好吧，我并没有。Factor帮助我保持正轨。高蛋白、低碳水、无乳制品，无论目标是什么。快来尝试Factor的优惠活动吧。在FactorMeals.ca使用优惠代码easy，即可享受11份免费餐食外加免费配送。即11份免费餐食加免费配送，仅限使用优惠代码easy。赶快行动吧，先到先得。
like grilled salmon, creamy shrimp pasta, and flavorful chicken bowls. Food that tastes like I worked for it, even though, well, I didn't. Factor helps me stay on track. High protein, low carb, no dairy, whatever the goal. Try Factor with one of their best offers. Get 11 free meals plus free shipping at FactorMeals.ca with code easy. That's 11 free meals plus free shipping, but only with code easy. Hurry, this won't last.
前往FactorMeals.C.C. www.ca。在为孩子们准备午餐的每一个夜晚背后，其实都充满了悬念。他们最后会吃蔬菜吗？面食能挺过第一口吗？午餐盒带回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？又或者，在切完黄瓜之前，你能看完第8集吗？选择Bell纯光纤网络，尊享Netflix和Disney Plus，每月仅需94加元起。
Go to FactorMeals.C.C. www.ca. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all? And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month.
签订两年期互联网合约并开通自动扣款，价格两年保持不变。访问bell.com.za了解详情并查询覆盖情况。Bell。连接就是一切。我是尼克·图图罗。你可能从《纽约重案组》（NYPD Blue）、《最长的一码》（The Longest Yard）或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》（Black Klansman）中认识我。但我也来自皇后区，这意味着我懂披萨。在我的新播客《与尼克·图图罗一起传递快乐》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Turturro）中，我把普林斯街披萨（Prince Street Pizza）的披萨送给一位新嘉宾。你现在在送披萨吗？
Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.com.za for details and to check availability. Bell. Connection is everything. I'm Nick Tatoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Titoro, I deliver pizza from Prince Street pizza to a new guest. Are you delivering pizza now?
然后我们坐下来进行一次真正的对话。我和每个人分享了一片披萨，从赛斯·罗林斯（Seth Rollins）。你在对我的金腰带做什么？到亚历克斯·罗德里格斯（Alex Rodriguez）。让你们大家知道，我们正在和这里的史上最佳（GOAT）之一交谈。比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr）。我觉得我从来没见过哪个人的精神状态像我一样这么出格。现在，我们还将迎来更多优秀的嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·图图罗（John Turturro）。这节目叫快乐，
Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing, my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here. Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness, Delivering Happiness.
传递快乐。还有许许多多精彩内容。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《与尼克·图图罗一起传递快乐》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Turturro）。并立即收听。我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》（Dear Chelsea）的切尔西·汉德勒（Chelsea Handler）。每周，新闻都在变得更糟。
Mariano Rivera. Oh, my God. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro. And listen now. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse.
世界变得更疯狂。而亚曼妮卡（Yamanika）来到这里，要对任何应该负责的人说：你才是问题所在。如果你来这里玩游戏，我会收拾你的。好吗？如果你在新闻里做了一些听起来不太妙的事，
The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible. you're the problem. If you come over here to play games, I'ma check you. Okay? If you do some in the news that don't sound good,
我要拿你开涮。加入亚曼妮卡·桑德斯（Yamanika Saunders），在她全新的播客节目中剖析本周最具问题的故事。《亚曼妮卡告诉你谁是问题所在》（You're the problem with Yamanika）。你知道我刚刚发现西德妮·西妮（Sydney Sweeney）是谁吗？
I'm gonna play you. Join Yomeneika Saunders as she breaks down the week's most problematic stories on her new podcast. You're the problem with Yamanika. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was?
每周三更新新剧集，这是我的新网络“亲爱的切尔西网络”（The Dear Chelsea Network）的一部分。如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。男人。做得更好，或者少做一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。所以请在每一集中加入亚曼妮卡，因为她要回答一个问题。谁才是问题所在？
New episodes weekly every Wednesday is part of my new network, the dear Chelsea Network. If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. men. Do better or do less so I don't have to do so much. So join Yamanika each episode as she answers one question. Who's the problem?
我是亚曼妮卡，我先走一步。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《亚曼妮卡告诉你谁是问题所在》（You're the problem with Yamanika）。以大多数标准来看，我们的小镇只是无名小卒，对吧？但对在这里长大的人来说，这里就是一切。当一个安静的田纳西州小镇成为争夺美国未来的前线时，会发生什么？
I'm Yamanika and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Our town is small taters by most standards, right? But to the people who grew up here, it's everything. What happens when a quiet Tennessee town becomes the front line in a battle over the the future of America. Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land in the area. The first thing you see when it pops up is pioneers in Appalachia.
拥有右翼背景的开发商已经在该地区购买了数百英亩的土地。当它弹出时，你看到的第一件事就是阿巴拉契亚的先锋。但他们不只是在规划房屋。我们需要山巅之城，成为基督教生活方式的典范和化身。
But they weren't just planning houses. We need cities on a shining hill that exemplify and embody the Christian way of life. Stop right there. Is that normal? A podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment. God need men to rule. Great. And decides to fight back.
停在那儿。这正常吗？这是一个关于当一个小镇成为社会实验场时会发生什么的播客。上帝需要男人来统治。太棒了。并决定进行反击。不要利用我的辛苦工作来兜售你们的胡言乱语。他们不仅是在反对这里正在规划的事。
Do not use my hard work to sell your bull. They're not just opposing what's being planned for here. Our hometown is not a test tube. They feel like they're standing in opposition to an entire administration. Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you? Listen to Our Town on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So the second way our nervous system becomes dysregulated is from prolonged experience. to things that lessen our ability to cope.
我们的家乡可不是试验管。他们觉得他们是在对抗整个政府。我想你们搬进来面对的不是一群笨乡巴佬，对吧？请在iHeart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《我们的城镇》（Our Town）。因此，我们的神经系统失调的第二种方式，来自于长期经历
This is not one big event like trauma with a big tea, the kind we just spoke about, but it is the slow accumulation of pressure, maybe from things like financial or work stress, caregiving stress, conflict, loneliness, academic pressure, unstable relationships. Most of us can tolerate these stresses for a short amount of time. But if they become the norm, the body just, can't and it keeps us in survival mode because it thinks that's where we need to be. The sympathetic nervous system, which is, we've already spoken about it, the one involved in vital flight, becomes dominant when this is occurring, meaning the body is going to spend
那些削弱我们应对能力的事物。这不是一件像大T创伤那样的大事件，也就是我们刚才谈到的那种，而是压力的缓慢积累，可能来自于财务或工作压力、照顾他人的压力、冲突、孤独、学业压力、不稳定的关系等事情。我们大多数人都能在短时间内承受这些压力。但如果它们成为了常态，身体就会，无法承受，并且它会让我们保持在生存模式，因为它认为那是我们需要待的地方。交感神经系统——我们已经讨论过了，就是那个参与战斗或逃跑的系统——在这种情况发生时会占据主导地位，这意味着身体会花费
far too much time thinking that it needs to be ready for action and not enough time recovering and coming down from that arousal. And this starts to feel normal. In fact, in his 1998 paper in the New England Journal of Medicine, Bruce McEwen, who is a foundational expert on this, explains that stress mediators protect us in the short term, but repeated activation over time creates a wear and tear that is similar to wearing the same shoes every single day or using a certain muscle every single day. It physically and psychologically is worn down and torn. This is explained through the concept of allostatic load, where our body adapts to the chronic stress through neural, hormonal, and immune responses when our stress systems are repeatedly
太多时间认为自己需要为行动做好准备，而没有花足够的时间来恢复并从这种唤醒中平静下来。而这开始让人觉得很正常。事实上，布鲁斯·麦克尤恩（Bruce McEwen）在其1998年发表在《新英格兰医学杂志》上的论文中——他是这方面的奠基专家——解释说，应激介质在短期内保护了我们，但随着时间的推移，反复激活会造成一种磨损，类似于每天穿同一双鞋，或者每天使用某个特定的肌肉。它在生理上和心理上都被磨损和撕裂了。这是通过“总体负荷”（allostatic load）的概念来解释的，当我们的压力系统随着时间的推移被反复激活，然后又不知道不处于那些状态是什么感觉时，我们的身体通过神经、激素和免疫反应来适应慢性压力。
activated over time and then doesn't know what it feels to not be in those states. Our body changes, our systems change, our response changes. And there comes a point where we just don't notice it. Like at the beginning we did, now we no longer do because of the chronic stress. Now the third route we need to talk about to nervous system dysregulation is lifestyle factors. And I know when we mention lifestyle, there often comes this narrative of like personal blame and choice and that you are choosing a dysregulated nervous system if you live this way. That is not what this reflects, you know.
我们的身体改变了，我们的系统改变了，我们的反应改变了。并且会达到这样一个点：我们根本没有注意到它。就像一开始我们注意到了，但现在由于慢性压力，我们不再注意了。现在我们要谈论的神经系统失调的第三个途径是生活方式因素。我知道当我们提到生活方式时，经常会出现一种关于个人责备和选择的叙事，即如果你这样生活，你就是在选择一个失调的神经系统。这并不是这所反映的内容，你知道的。
We're not saying like if you adopt a certain lifestyle, you are responsible for your dysregulated nervous system. I just want to point out some of the things that contribute on top of trauma and often on top of chronic stress as well. The first one is porcel. Poor sleep is a huge one that has been shown to significantly worsen our ability to stay within our window for tolerance in a very profound way. But other things that we don't even realize, like under-eating, too much caffeine, lack of movement, too much screen time, too much alcohol, constant busyness can all make the body more reactive and prone to stress. Simply put, if your system is already under-resourced by a lack of sleep, by a lack of sleep, by the,
我们并不是说如果你采取了某种生活方式，你就要为自己失调的神经系统负责。我只是想指出除了创伤之外，而且通常也是除了慢性压力之外，还促成这一现象的一些事情。第一点是睡眠质量差。睡眠质量差是一个巨大的因素，它已被证明会以一种非常深远的方式显著削弱我们保持在耐受窗口内的能力。但还有一些我们甚至没有意识到的事情，比如营养不良、咖啡因过多、缺乏运动、屏幕时间过多、酒精摄入过多、持续的忙碌，都会让身体更容易产生反应并更容易承受压力。简而言之，如果你的系统已经因为缺乏睡眠、缺乏营养、缺乏休息而资源不足，它容忍压力的能力就会降低。我认为这也表明，
a lack of nutrition, by a lack of rest, it has less capacity to tolerate stress. It also goes to show, I think, that regulation begins with very basic signals of safety. Rest, nutrition, daylight, movement, connection. If those don't feel adequate, it cannot be fixed by yoga or breathwork or meditation. Luxuries do not fix basic problems, especially when they happen in combination with chronic and traumatic experiences. I think a really important aspect of nervous system regulation and why I'm such a big fan of the topic is that it really shows us that these responses like anxiety, like stress, like burnout, like trauma, they aren't just in our heads. They are felt in the body. Your emotional reaction, your psychological reactions have a home
调节始于非常基本的安全信号。休息、营养、日光、运动、连接。如果这些让人感觉不够充分，单靠瑜伽、呼吸法或冥想是无法解决问题的。奢侈品无法解决根本问题，尤其是当它们与慢性经历和创伤经历结合在一起时。我认为神经系统调节的一个非常重要的方面，也是我为什么如此喜欢这个话题的原因，在于它真正向我们表明，这些反应——比如焦虑、压力、精疲力竭、创伤——不仅仅存在于我们的脑海中。它们是被身体所感受到的。你的情绪反应、你的心理反应在你的神经系统中有一个归宿。
within your nervous system. And I think it shifts us away from a previous narrative that was all about, cognition, you know, your life will be better if you just reframe how you're thinking. Your problems are your thoughts. What nervous system regulation says and why I think so many people resonate with it is that, no, you have these ancient survival mechanisms. Something along the way has disturbed, changed how these systems operate. I think I love this switch analogy. Somebody has gone in and reset like the control board. Somebody has gone in and flipped to switch and now how these systems were meant to function is no longer how they do. And that starts to feel normal to you. The question is though, when we've been in this state for so long, how do we go about noticing it,
我认为这让我们从之前那种完全围绕认知的叙事中转变出来，你知道的，那种认为只要你重新构架自己的思维方式，生活就会变得更好的观点。你的问题就是你的想法。神经系统调节所说的，以及为什么我认为这么多人与之产生共鸣的原因是，不，你拥有这些古老的生存机制。这一路上的某些东西扰乱了、改变了这些系统的运作方式。我想我非常喜欢这个开关的比喻。有人进去重置了控制板。有人进去扳动了开关，现在这些系统原本应该如何运作已经不再是它们的运作方式了。而这开始让你觉得很正常。不过问题是，当我们处于这种状态这么久之后，我们该如何去注意到它呢，
right? I keep saying, oh, you get to a point where you don't notice it. But at some point, you know, there is a sliver of awareness and awareness is required. How do we gain access to Like, how do we start to realize, like, something in my body and with my nervous system isn't making sense? I mean, I'll give you a little bit of a list of the 10 biggest things that you may notice in your body that might indicate dysregulation. Number one is disproportionate and uncontrollable emotional and physical responses. You snap at a simple request from your partner or your friend.
对吧？我一直说，哦，你会达到一个你注意不到它的点。但在某个时刻，你知道的，会有一丝觉察，而觉察是必需的。我们如何获得——就像，我们如何开始意识到，我身体里的某处和我的神经系统有些不对劲？我的意思是，我给你列一个你可能会在身体中注意到的10件大事的清单，这些可能表明了失调。第一点是不成比例且无法控制的情绪和身体反应。你对伴侣或朋友的一个简单请求大发雷霆。
A small task at work feels unbearably stressful. committing to plans triggers a wave of anxiety. But equally, things that should be stressful, sometimes you just couldn't care less about. Again, your responses are illogical. Secondly, you feel wired but tired. Hypervigilant on all the time. Even when you're trying to sleep, you never feel rested. It's like that feeling, the best way you can describe it, is like when you try and catch a 5 a.m. flight from a busy airport, and you're like, I'm so tired, but I'm so awake right now. Third, you startle easily, even at the most insignificant things. Four, you often have moments of realizing how tense you have been. And even when you, like, go to
工作中的一个小任务让你感到无法忍受的压力。承诺做计划会引发一波焦虑。但同样地，有时那些本该让你感到压力的事情，你却完全不在乎。再次说明，你的反应是不合逻辑的。第二，你感到亢奋却又疲惫。高度警惕，随时处于开启状态。即使在你试图睡觉的时候，你也从不觉得休息好了。那种感觉，你所能描述的最好方式，就像是当你试图赶一早5点从繁忙机场起飞的航班时，你会想，我太累了，但我现在又如此清醒。第三，你很容易受到惊吓，即使是对最微不足道的事情也是如此。第四，你经常会有这样的时刻：意识到自己一直以来有多么紧绷。甚至当你，比如，去放松前额、放松肩膀或下巴时，总感觉好像还有一些紧张留存着，就像有些紧张感某种程度上卡在你体内，无论如何也揉不掉。第五，你很易怒。你发现自己很难与人相处。你发现自己以前觉得很放松的事情现在不那么放松了。第六，是脑雾。你的注意力集中能力也大大下降了。你的记忆力可能看起来有点问题。即使那是让你兴奋的事情，即使你睡了个完美的好觉，你的注意力上方似乎也笼罩着这样一种阴云，它一直萦绕不去，而你会从你正在做的事情中走神，然后又回过神来，接着又走神。你知道我之前提到过这个，但就像你真的很难入睡，你很难保持睡眠。
relax your forehead or go to relax your shoulders or your jaw, it feels like there's always some tension, like, left over, like some tension kind of stuck in you that, like, you can never rub out. Five, you're irritable. You find it hard to be around people. You don't find things that you used to do very relaxing. Six, is brain fog. Your ability to concentrate has also diminished greatly. Your memory might seem a little bit off. Even if it's something that you're excited about, even if you got the perfect night's sleep, there seems to be this kind of cloud over your focus that just like lingers and you kind of snap away and snap back in and snap away from what you're doing. And you know I kind of mention this, but like you really struggle to sleep, you struggle to get to sleep,
即使你睡了个好觉，你也没有得到休息。你经常会有脱离现实的感觉。这是另一个大问题，而且非常虚幻。所谓的时刻，你知道的，我可以指几分钟、几小时、几天长时间的解离，在这些时间里，你感觉不到自己在身体里，你感觉不到自己在世界中，这也会非常非常快地变得非常非常可怕。最后，你会发现你没有任何对成长的心向或拓展的欲望。记住，当你陷入长期的激活状态或背侧迷走神经关闭状态时，
you struggle to stay asleep. Even when you get a good night's sleep, you don't feel rested. You often have moments of feeling detached from reality. That's another big one and very floaty. And by moments, you know, I can mean minutes, I can mean hours, I can mean days of prolonged dissociation where you don't feel in your body, you don't feel in your world, and that can get very, very scary, very, very quickly as well. And finally, you find you lack any desire or expansion for growth. Remember, when you are stuck in chronic activation or in dorsal vagal shutdown,
这些状态不利于也不旨在帮助你投资未来。它们的存在是为了帮助你度过当下，而成长和体验——成长和拓展需要完全相反的东西。它们需要腹侧迷走神经状态，在这种状态下，身体有足够的备用容量和资源来探索、冒险、学习和建立连接。好奇心、兴奋感、新鲜感、拓展，都是情感上的奢侈品，
these states are not conducive or designed to help you invest in the future. They exist to help you survive the present, growth and experience. growth and expansion require the opposite. They require the ventral vagal state, where the body has enough spare capacity and resources to explore and to take risks and to learn and to connect. Curiosity, excitement, novelty, expansion, are emotional luxuries,
而你在目前这段时间里将无法获得它们。所以，当我们在这个地方呆了这么久之后，一个被调节的神经系统究竟是什么感觉？我们怎么还能知道我们错过了什么？这对很多人来说是个大问题。A，我们真的无法识别，比如，真的，我认为这是最大的问题。我们无法真正识别出我们已经超出了耐受窗口，因为我们已经好几年或好几十年没有处于耐受窗口中了。
and they will remain inaccessible to you for the time being. So when we've been in this place for so long, what does a regulated nervous system even feel like anymore? How do we even know what we're missing? This is a big thing for a lot of people. A, we can't really recognize, like, really, I think it's the biggest issue. We can't really recognize that we are outside of our window for tolerance, because we haven't been in our window for tolerance for years or for decades.
所以当人们谈论，你知道的，一个被调节的神经系统时，我们几乎会觉得，我不需要那个，因为这很正常，不是吗？因为我们无法想象有任何不同会是什么感觉。所以一个被调节的神经系统究竟是什么感觉？如果你在这个地方被困了这么久，比如你如何——A，是的，注意到你失调了，B，你如何还记得不这样生活是什么感觉？问题是，很多人并不记得，而且他们也，他们简直无法想象
And so when people talk about, you know, a regulated nervous system, we almost feel like, I don't need that because this is normal, is it not? because we can't imagine what it feels like to have anything differently. So what does a regulated nervous system even feel like? If you've been stuck in this place for so long, like how do you, A, yes, notice that you are dysregulated, B, how do you remember what it even feels like to not be this way? The thing is, many people don't, and they also, they just simply cannot imagine. the alternative. One of the biggest symptoms of trauma and chronic stress is what psychologists
另一种可能。创伤和慢性生活压力的最大症状之一，就是心理学家所说的
call a sense of foreshortened future. You physically cannot picture yourself in the future. You deeply believe I'm going to die young. You cannot imagine yourself in a happy relationship with a happy work life, in a good job or in old age. And what they found is that your sense of time itself is affected. your safety has been so threatened in the past that to believe it will not be threatened again in the future is to go against a deep, deep survival instinct, which is to always prepare for the worst, which is to always be on high alert. If you are preparing for the worst all the time, it becomes impossible to imagine the best or even the existence of more. Now this changes you as a person.
被称为一种“对未来的短视感”。你的生理机能无法在脑海中想象出自己的未来。你深信自己会英年早逝。你无法想象自己拥有一段幸福的恋情、满意的工作、优秀的事业，或者能够安度晚年。研究发现，你对时间的感知本身也受到了影响。你的安全感在过去曾受到如此严重的威胁，以至于要去相信它未来不会再次受到威胁，就等同于违背了一个极其深层的生存本能——那就是时刻为最坏的情况做准备，时刻保持高度警惕。如果你一直在为最坏的情况做准备，那就根本无法想象最好情况的发生，甚至无法想象拥有更多可能性的存在。而这会改变你作为一个人的本质。
This constant state of prepare for the worst, always, be on high alert, means you struggle to do anything but survive. It means you struggle again for expansion and for curiosity. Many people confuse the actions of a dysregulated nervous system with their personality or with a character floor. You know, I can't manage my diary. I feel so overwhelmed by plans. because I'm a bad friend, that must be why it is. You know, I snap at my partner. I'm really moody
这种永远在为最坏情况做准备、永远保持高度警惕的持续状态，意味着你除了维持生存之外，很难去做任何别的事情。这也意味着你在追求自我拓展和好奇心时会举步维艰。许多人把神经系统失调的表现误认为是他们的个性或性格缺陷。你知道的，比如“我管理不好自己的日程，我被各种计划压得喘不过气来，因为我是一个糟糕的朋友，事情一定就是这样的”。你知道的，比如“我对伴侣大发雷霆，我情绪非常无常”
because I'm not capable of love. I can't follow through on ideas because I am just lazy. I'm a lazy person. I'm no good. I'm a bad person. What you need to understand is that when your nervous system is dysregulated, you have this big control board in front of you and the wiring behind it is all wrong. So you push buttons and you're like, great, I want to do this and a completely different reaction is produced. Like, that is what you are kind of dealing with. Further evidence that this isn't personal and that it isn't a personality floor or a character flaw, but, you know, physiological and psychological is case studies. Case studies are people who suddenly feel safe after years of not, who get out of bad environments and their entire life shift. There is still anger. There is still
是因为我不配拥有爱。我无法坚持贯彻各种想法，纯粹是因为我很懒。我是一个懒惰的人。我真没用。我是一个糟糕的人。你需要明白的是，当你的神经系统失调时，你面前就像有一个巨大的控制面板，而它背后的线路全连错了。所以当你按下按钮，心里想着：太好了，我想做这个，结果却产生了一种完全不同的反应。这就是你目前正在应对的状况。更有力的证据表明，这并非个人问题，也不是性格缺陷或品行瑕疵，而是生理和心理层面的，这可以从个案研究中看出。个案研究的对象是那些在经历了多年的缺乏安全感之后，突然感到安全的人，是那些摆脱了恶劣环境、从而整个人生发生转变的人。愤怒依然存在，
sadness, but it feels like they suddenly have enough space between a feeling and a response where they can insert their own agency. And I think that's what a regulated nervous system really represents. It's just choice. Like, I can choose my reaction to my reaction. I have an expanded sense of my own ability. My emotional capacity has improved. I feel like I am in control. So if we've been in this date for a while, can we actually fix what has become dysregulated? The psychology says yes. Polyvagal theory says yes if we understand the science of safety and how to support homeostatic functions that promote growth, but then also restoration and flourishing. Homostatic basically just means steady state. And it is a scientific principle
悲伤也依然存在，但他们感觉自己突然在某种情感与反应之间留出了足够的空间，能够介入并展现出自己的自主性。我想，这才是调节良好的神经系统真正代表的含义。它仅仅意味着选择。就像，我可以选择自己对某种反应的反应。我对自身能力的感知得到了拓宽。我的情绪承载力提升了。我感觉一切尽在掌控。因此，如果我们处于这种状态已经有一段时间了，我们真的能修复这个已经失调的系统吗？心理学研究表明：可以。多迷走神经理论表明：只要我们理解了关于安全的科学原理，懂得如何支持那些促进生长、恢复以及蓬勃发展的体内平衡功能，答案就是肯定的。这里的“体内平衡”基本上就是指稳态。这是一个科学原理，
that describes how organisms like you and I can only function if their internal conditions are kept within a specific range. Basically, what we're describing is the window for tolerance. Crucially, though, the timeline for getting back and really experiencing homeostasis is going to differ for everybody. It really is based on how long this has been happening for, whether you're still living in the conditions
它描述了像你我这样的生物，只有在内部条件保持在一个特定范围内时才能正常运作。基本上，我们所描述的就是耐受窗口。不过至关重要的是，每个人恢复并真正体验到体内平衡的时间线会有所不同。这完全取决于这种情况已经持续了多久、你是否依然生活在那些
that keep this system activated, and whether you have the support around you to get you out of this place. If dysregulation is linked to a short period of stress, If you've had a really tough few weeks at work, you've been through a breakup, you are experiencing insomnia, it may settle relatively quickly once the stressor reduces and the body has enough time to recover. In those cases, it's less about something that's been rewired or retrained. It's more just about giving your overworked nervous system space and some time to rest and consistency to just like back down and just calm down. But if dysregulation, especially the kind we've been describing, has been present for months or for years, or if it's linked to trauma or chronic stress or long-term emotional unsafety, it is going to take longer because the nervous system has had more time to learn that high alert is necessary for survival. What has been reinforced repeatedly usually needs repeated experiences to safely shift.
让这个系统保持激活状态的环境中，以及你的周围是否有足够的支持能把你带出这种绝境。如果失调与一段短暂的压力期有关，如果你在工作上度过了非常艰难的几周，经历了一场分手，或者正在遭受失眠的困扰，那么一旦应激源减弱，且身体有足够的时间恢复，这种失调可能会相对较快地平息。在这些情况下，它较少涉及被重新布线或重新训练，更多的是在于给你那过度劳累的神经系统一些空间、休息时间以及稳定性，让它能够自行退让和平复。但是，如果失调——尤其是我们一直在描述的那种失调——已经持续了数月或数年，或者它与创伤、慢性压力或长期的情感缺乏安全感有关，那么修复它就需要更长的时间，因为神经系统有更多的时间来学习到高警惕对于生存是必不可少的。那些被反复强化过的经历，通常需要通过重复的体验来进行安全的转变。
off. We know this through research on neuroplasticity, including a very famous paper published by, where was it published by researchers at Harvard, I think, Harvard Medical School back in like the mid-2000s, that essentially says the brain remains capable of change throughout your life, but this change is difficult and it's shaped by repetition, it's shaped by context and experience. So if you've experienced repeated stress and a sense of unsafe, it would follow, kind of that like an equal number of safe experiences are required to reverse the influence of unsafe experiences. Now, psychological safety doesn't just mean the absence of threat. That is something that a lot of people perhaps get wrong. It's of course number one. You can't do anything
神经可塑性的研究证实了这一点，其中包括一篇非常著名的论文，它由哈佛大学的研究人员发表，我想应该是在2000年代中期由哈佛医学院发表的。该论文的基本观点是：大脑在你的一生中都保持着改变的能力，但这种改变是困难的，它由重复塑造，并由环境和经验所塑造。因此，如果你经历过重复的压力和不安全感，那么顺理成章地，也需要等量的安全体验去逆转那些不安全体验的影响。现在，心理安全不仅仅意味着没有威胁。这是许多人可能弄错的一点。当然，这是第一位的。如果你觉得你所处的地方不安全，你就什么也做不了。
if you feel like you are unsafe where you are. But it also means something more. It means the availability of resources needed for more than survival, for flourishing. It also requires the presence of choice. It requires the presence of support and also just the knowledge to self-regulate. I like to think of this as like a pyramid. And what sits at the bottom is required to reach the pinnacle. At the bottom of the pyramid is the foundations. It is sleep. It is nourishment. It is warmth. It is medical care. It's predictable routines. If you are sleeping only four hours a night, as we said, if you are under-reading, if you are living in chaos, if you are constantly checking messages from someone who makes you feel awful, or if you are, if you really, if you have a job
但它同时也意味着更多的东西。它意味着拥有不仅仅为了生存、更是为了蓬勃发展所需的资源。它还需要选择的存在。它需要支持的存在，同时也需要进行自我调节的知识。我喜欢把这想象成一座金字塔。处于底部的部分是攀登顶峰所必需的。金字塔的底部是地基。它是睡眠。它是营养。它是温暖。它是医疗护理。它是规律的日常作息。正如我们所说，如果你每晚只睡四个小时，如果你营养不良，如果你生活在混乱之中，如果你不断查看某个让你感觉糟糕的人发来的信息，或者如果你真的有一份
that just makes you feel awful all the time, there is, I know this is going to sound controversial, but very little that you can do beyond improving those things that is going to fix your nervous system. You cannot apply luxuries like an ice bath or luxury. like red light therapy onto a lack of sleep and think that it's going to have the same effect. So we need to fulfill those basic requirements. Following that and sitting close to it is choice. A sense of agency, as we already know, is foundational for a regulated nervous system. Because how are you meant to feel safe ever if you can't control what's going to happen to you
总是让你感到糟糕的工作，那么——我知道这听起来可能会引起争议——除了改善这些事情之外，几乎没有什么其他办法能够修复你的神经系统。你不能把冰浴或红外线疗法这种奢侈品叠加在严重缺乏睡眠的基础上，还指望它能产生相同的效果。因此，我们需要满足这些基本需求。紧随其后且与之密切相关的是选择。正如我们已经知道的那样，自主感是调节良好的神经系统的基石。因为如果你无法控制接下来会发生什么，或者无法控制你想参与的事情，你怎么可能感到安全呢？
or what you want to engage in? even if everything in your life is taken care of. If you don't have a say in how it is taken care of, or what you need to do to have it taken care of, or what would happen if it wasn't taken care of, your nervous system will remain on high alert. In psychology, this is called perceived control. In the 1970s, this researcher from Yale University,
哪怕你生活中的一切都被照顾得妥妥贴贴。如果你对如何照顾这些事情、你需要做什么来照顾这些事情，或者如果没有照顾好会发生什么没有发言权，你的神经系统依然会保持高度警惕。在心理学中，这被称为感知控制。在20世纪70年代，这位来自耶鲁大学的研究人员，
his name is Dr. Jay Weiss, he demonstrated in a series of experiments with rats how important choice really is. In this experiment, he subjected two groups of rats to simultaneous electric shocks, but one group of these rats could exit the box where it was receiving the shock. The other couldn't. They both experienced the same voltage, the same number of shocks. They went through this round and round again. But after they received a shock, one rat could walk through a door and lean.
他的名字叫杰·韦斯博士（Dr. Jay Weiss），他在一系列对老鼠进行的实验中证明了选择究竟有多么重要。在这项实验中，他让两组老鼠同时承受电击，但其中一组老鼠可以离开遭受电击的箱子，而另一组则不能。它们经历着相同的电压，相同次数的电击。它们一次又一次地经历这个过程。但在遭受电击之后，其中一只老鼠可以穿过一扇门并靠着
the other one couldn't. The availability of a way out didn't take the pain away, but it was enough to lower a stress response in the rat that felt it could do something and it could escape and it could move. It isn't the exercising of the choice that regulates the nervous system or reduces the pain of trauma. It's that knowing that a door exists, that if you needed to, you could, you could escape, you could leave, you could make a choice about this. So if you do not have choice, if you do not feel like I can change these circumstances, if you do not feel like I can choose a different alternative, like your system is never going to be regulated. Everything around you could be going really well, but if you were in a job where you're like, I don't feel like I'm in
另一只则不能。逃生途径的存在并没有消除痛苦，但它足以降低那些觉得自己能做点什么、能够逃脱并能够行动的老鼠的应激反应。行使选择权本身并没有调节神经系统或减轻创伤痛苦，真正起作用的是那种知道有一扇门存在的感觉——如果你需要的话，你可以逃脱，你可以离开，你可以对此做出选择。因此，如果你没有选择，如果你不觉得“我可以改变这些环境”，如果你不觉得“我可以选择另一种替代方案”，那么你的系统就永远无法得到调节。你周围的一切可能都进展顺利，但如果你身处一份让你觉得“我无法掌控自己的环境”的工作中，
control of my circumstances. If you are in a relationship where you don't feel in control, if you're in even if that's like a family system where you don't feel in control, yes, basic things could be taken care of, but you could still experience this hyper or hypo arousal. The next level in the pyramid are stabilizing practices. So once we have basic needs and choice down pat, things like gentle movement, getting enough daylight, consistent meals, reducing stimulants, getting outdoors, creating routines that provide the body with predictability are the next think it's going to help regulate a nervous system. The reason this is so important is that it allows the brain to stop constantly trying to predict what comes next and it stops needing to work so hard.
如果你处于一段让你感觉失去控制的关系中，哪怕那是一个让你感到无法掌控的家庭系统——是的，基本需求可能得到了照顾，但你依然可能会经历这种过度觉醒或觉醒不足。金字塔的下一层是稳定练习。因此，一旦我们将基本需求和选择落实到位，像温和的运动、获得充足的日光、规律的饮食、减少兴奋剂摄入、走向户外、建立能为身体提供可预测性的常规作息，就是接下来被认为有助于调节神经系统的做法。之所以如此重要，是因为它能让大脑停止不断试图预测接下来会发生什么，并停止过度运转。
And in that space of ambiguity, feeling like it needs to shoot you in these different directions. After that is relational regulation. So safe people, co-regulation, therapy, support groups, affection, feeling seen. Those are things people don't always speak about in terms of nervous system regulation but is so important. In a 1985 paper, authors Cohen and Willis, they talk about this theory called the stress buffering hypothesis. And what they essentially say is that, you know, the stress buffering hypothesis, what that basically says and argues is that social support is particularly important for protecting well-being, not just because it's nice, but because it buffers people from the harmful effects of stressful events, especially when support is
在那种充满不确定性、感觉需要将你朝各个不同方向推搡的空间里，这就显得尤为关键。接下来是关系调节。因此，安全的人、共调节、治疗、支持小组、关爱、被人看见的感觉。这些都是人们在谈论神经系统调节时并不总是会提及，但却极其重要的事情。在1985年的一篇论文中，作者科恩和威利斯（Cohen and Willis）探讨了一个名为“压力缓冲假说”的理论。他们本质上指出的是，压力缓冲假说，其核心所表达和论证的是：社会支持对于保护幸福感尤来重要，这不仅仅是因为它感觉很好，而是因为它能缓冲人们免受压力事件带来的有害影响，尤其是当这种支持
perceived as responsive and individual. We cannot underestimate the impact of sitting with somebody and knowing that if something went wrong, we would have somebody to call. The body often borrows safety before it can learn to generate it alone. I also think that this is why we overlook factors like loneliness in contributing to nervous system dysregulation. Again, I think this is a disservice that has been done in how this is described. We think that it's only high stress, the addition of stressful experiences, dangerous experiences.
被认为是积极响应且因人而异的时候。我们绝不能低估与某人坐在一起、并深知如果出了问题我们还有人可以打电话的那种影响。身体往往会在学会独自产生安全感之前，先向外界借取安全感。我也认为，这就是为什么我们会忽视诸如孤独感等因素对神经系统失调所起到的推波助澜作用。同样，我认为在描述这一机制时，我们所采用的方式其实是一种伤害。我们以为只有高度压力、叠加的压力经历以及危险经历，
But feeling lonely and feeling like you don't really have friends or you don't really have a good support system for a prolonged period of time, will dysregulate your nervous system the same way that experiencing a really intense catastrophic event might do so. Yes, they target the brain and the body and the mind differently, but they still are both pathways to feeling dysregulated. I'd argue that social support also includes the more targeted psychological work too. So therapy, the CBT, the exposure-based work, the EMDR, and medication as well, where appropriate. And with that as well, the skills for emotional regulation.
才会导致失调。但感到孤独，并且在长期的状况下觉得你真的没有朋友，或者没有一个好的支持系统，同样会使你的神经系统失调，其程度不亚于经历了一次真正剧烈的灾难性事件。是的，它们针对大脑、身体和心灵的方式不同，但它们通往神经系统失调的路径是相同的。我想说的是，社会支持也包括更具针对性的心理工作。比如心理治疗、认知行为疗法（CBT）、基于暴露的疗法、眼动脱敏再加工疗法（EMDR），以及在适当情况下的药物治疗。与之相伴的，还有情绪调节的技巧。
Like, these are the necessary interventions for when this chronic or, overwhelming sense of dysregulation can't just be solved by more sleep or eating better. As much as I'm saying, these are foundational, like, sometimes again, there just is a lot going on in your life that you've never been taught to deal with. And if nobody ever teaches you how to deal with it or gives you the ability to rationalize things that can be rationalized or to process things that, like, feel inaccessible to you, you're not going to feel any better. at the top is when we get the luxuries, the saunas, the retreats, the expensive glasses, the gadgets, the supplements, biohacking, cold plungers, all these things.
诸如此类，当这种慢性的或压倒性的失调感无法仅仅通过多睡觉或吃得更好来解决时，这些就是必不可少的干预措施。尽管我在强调这些是基础，但有时候，你的生活中确实有很多事情是你从未被教导过如何处理的。如果从来没有人教过你如何处理这些事情，或者没有赋予你将可以合理化的事情进行合理化的能力、亦或是去处理那些对你来说感觉遥不可及的事情的能力，你的情况是不会有任何好转的。位于金字塔顶端的是那些奢侈品，比如桑拿、静修营、昂贵的眼镜、各种小玩意儿、补充剂、生物黑客疗法、冷水浸浴，所有这些东西。
These may be enjoyable and they're definitely helpful in certain cases. But these are not the base. And this is my whole point with talking about the foundations of nervous system regulation. The wellness industry will have us thinking that we are, you know, one cold plunge away from being calm. But we're not. What we really need to do is to stop ignoring the fundamentals that actually carry the nervous system and stop believing that the reason our nervous system isn't regulated is because we don't have the money to do all these things all the time that people are selling to us.
这些或许令人愉快，而且在某些情况下确实有所帮助。但这些并非根基。这就是我谈论神经系统调节基础的核心观点。健康产业让我们误以为，我们距离平静似乎只差一次冷水浸浴。但事实并非如此。我们真正需要做的是，停止忽视那些真正承载着神经系统的基础要素，停止相信我们的神经系统之所以无法调节，是因为我们没有钱去永远购买别人向我们兜售的所有这些东西。
So with that in mind, we're going to take a short break, and then we're going to discuss the free stuff that is actually available to basically every single human being to regulate their nervous system. It doesn't have a price tag. We're not going to gatekeep it. it is hardwired into our body as a way to calm down and feel regulated. So stay with us. I like to eat well. But after work, after errands, after everything else, cooking just doesn't happen.
带着这个想法，我们将稍作休息，然后讨论那些实际上对几乎每一个人都触手可及的、能够用来调节其神经系统的免费资源。它们没有标价。我们不会对其进行信息把关。它们作为一种平静下来并感到受到调节的方式，已经深深镌刻在我们的身体里。所以请继续收听。我喜欢吃得好。但在工作之后、跑完各种零星琐事以及做完其他所有事情之后，做饭这件事根本无法实现。
That's why I started using Factor. Factor delivers fresh, never frozen, ready to eat meals. Designed by dietitians for balanced nutrition that actually fits my life. No prep, no cleanup. Just heat, eat, and move on. And just like that, I get my time. back. No dishes, no poor choices, no dinner stress. I don't have to plan. And somehow, I'm still eating meals like grilled salmon, creamy shrimp pasta, and flavorful chicken bowls, food that tastes like
这就是我开始使用Factor的原因。Factor提供新鲜、从不冷冻、即食的餐食。由营养师设计，提供真正适合我生活的均衡营养。无需备餐，无需清理。只需加热、享用，然后继续忙别的。就这样，我的时间回来了。没有盘子要洗，没有糟糕的选择，没有晚餐的压力。我不需要做计划。而且不知为何，我依然能吃到烤三文鱼、奶油虾仁意面和风味鸡肉碗等美食，这些食物的味道...
I worked for it, even though, well, I didn't. Factor helps me stay on track. High protein, low carb, no dairy, whatever the goal. Try Factor with one of their best offers. Get 11 free meals plus free shipping at factormeals.ca with code easy. That's 11 free meals plus free shipping, but only with code easy. Hurry, this won't last. Go to factormeals.ca. Factormeals.ca. Behind every night spent making the kids lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pesto survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all? And will you finish episode eight before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get bell. Well, Pure Fiber Internet with craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month.
就像是我精心烹制的一样，尽管，好吧，我其实并没有。Factor帮我保持健康状态。高蛋白、低碳水、无乳糖，无论你的目标是什么。通过他们的优惠来试用Factor吧。使用优惠码 easy，在 factormeals.ca 订购即可享受 11 餐免费外加免运费。这就是 11 餐免费加免运费，但仅限使用优惠码 easy。抓紧时间，优惠有限。访问 factormeals.ca。Factormeals.ca。在每个陪伴孩子准备午餐的夜晚背后，都充满了悬念。他们会终于吃掉蔬菜吗？青酱能在第一口之后幸存吗？饭盒带回家时会是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？在你切好黄瓜之前，你能看完第八集吗？Bell，为您提供纯光纤网络，并可享用令人向往的 Netflix 和 Disney Plus，每月仅需 94 美元起。
Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.com for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. I'm Nick Tuturo. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Totoro, I deliver pizza from Prince Street pizza to a new guest.
两年期网络套餐价格保证两年不变，并享有自动扣款优惠。访问 bell.com 了解详情并查询可用性。Bell，连接意味着一切。我是尼克·图图罗（Nick Turturro）。你可能通过《纽约重案组》、《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》认识我。但我也来自皇后区，这意味着我懂披萨。在我的新播客《尼克·图图罗传递快乐》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Turturro）中，我将把王子街披萨（Prince Street Pizza）的披萨送到一位新嘉宾手中。
Are you delivering pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here. To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am.
你现在是在送披萨吗？然后我们坐下来进行一次真正的对话。我和各种各样的人分享过一块披萨，从赛斯·罗林斯（Seth Rollins）——你在对我的金腰带做什么？到亚历山大·罗德里格斯（Alex Rodriguez）。让你们大家知道，我们正在和史上最伟大的人物之一交谈。再到比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr）。我想我从来没见过哪个人的精神状态像我一样这么出格。
And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Titoro. It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness. Mariano Rivera. Oh, my God. And many, many more. Open your free high-heart radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Duturo.
现在，我们还将迎来更多伟大的嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·图图罗（John Turturro）。这个节目叫“快乐”。传递快乐。马里亚诺·里维拉（Mariano Rivera）。哦，天哪。还有很多很多其他人。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《尼克·图图罗传递快乐》。
And listen now. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. If you come over here to play games, I'm a check you. Okay? If you do some in the news that don't sound good, I'm going to play you.
现在就去收听。我是切尔西·汉德勒（Chelsea Handler），来自《亲爱的切尔西》（Dear Chelsea）。每周，新闻都变得更糟。世界变得更疯狂。亚曼妮卡（Yamanika）来到这里，要对任何应负责任的人说：你才是问题所在。如果你来这里搞把戏，我会治一治你。好吧？如果你在新闻里做出什么听起来不妙的事，我要曝光你。
Join Yomeneka Saunders as she breaks down the week's most problematic stories on our new podcast. You're The Problem with Yomeneka. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? New episodes weekly every Wednesday is part of my new network, the Dear Chelsea Network. If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much. So join Yamanika each episode as she answers one question.
加入亚曼妮卡·桑德斯（Yamanika Saunders），她在我们的新播客《你才是问题所在，亚曼妮卡》（You're The Problem with Yamanika）中剖析本周最具问题的故事。你知道我刚刚发现西德妮·斯威尼（Sydney Sweeney）是谁吗？每周三更新新剧集，这是我的新网络“亲爱的切尔西网络”（The Dear Chelsea Network）的一部分。如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。要么表现好点，要么少做点，免得我得做那么多。所以每集都加入亚曼妮卡，她将回答一个问题。
Who's the problem? I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Our town is small taters by most standards, right? But to the people who grew up here, it's everything. What happens when a quiet Tennessee town becomes the front line in a battle over the future of America? Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land in the area.
谁才是问题所在？我是亚曼妮卡，我先走一步。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcast 或任何你听播客的地方收听亚曼妮卡的《你才是问题所在》。按大多数标准来看，我们的小镇都是个不起眼的小地方，对吧？但对在这里长大的人来说，这里就是一切。当一个安静的田纳西州小镇成为美国未来争夺战的前线时，会发生什么？有右翼背景的开发商在当地购买了数百英亩土地。
The first thing you see when it pops up is pioneers in Appalachia. But they weren't just planning houses. We need cities on a shining hill that exemplify and embody the Christian way of life. Stop right there. Is that normal? A podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment. God need bad to rule. Great. And decides to fight back. Do not use my hard work to sell your bull-h-h-h-hue.
当你弹出的第一个页面上看到的是阿巴拉契亚的先驱时。但他们不仅仅是在规划房屋。我们需要山巅之城，来践行和体现基督教的生活方式。等一下。这正常吗？这是一个关于当一个小镇成为社会实验场时会发生什么的播客。上帝需要恶棍来统治。太棒了。并决定进行反击。不要用我的辛勤劳动来推销你们的废话。
They're not just opposing what's being planned for here. Our hometown is not a test tube. They feel like they're standing in opposition to an entire administration. Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you? Listen to our town on the I-heart. radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Now that we know the basics of nervous system regulation, what it is, what it isn't, and the pyramid of needs, where does that leave us practically? Well, there are a few kind of key areas to look at where we can gradually start
他们不仅在反对这里正在规划的事物。我们的家乡可不是试验管。他们觉得他们是在对抗整个行政当局。猜你们搬进来时没料到会遇到一群愚蠢的乡巴佬吧？在 iHeart radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你听播客的地方收听《我们的镇》（Our Town）。既然我们知道了神经系统调节的基础知识——它是什么、它不是什么，以及需求金字塔——那在实际操作中，我们该从何着手呢？嗯，有一些关键领域我们可以开始逐步做到这一点，
reducing the amount of threat our body is having to manage. The first is perhaps unsurprising, considering what we've spoken about. But it's knowing when this needs more than just self-help advice. Self-guided regulation is incredibly useful. And it should probably be taught to us much earlier, even in childhood, even in schools, if you were going to ask me. But if your symptoms are seriously affecting everything about your life and you have tried everything to try and fix it,
减少我们的身体需要应对的威胁量。考虑到我们刚刚讨论过的内容，第一点或许并不让人意外。那就是要知道什么时候这已经不仅仅需要自助建议了。自我引导的调节非常有用。而且如果让我说的话，它很早就应该教给我们，甚至在童年时期，在学校里就该教。但如果你的症状已经严重影响了你生活的方方面面，并且你已经尝试了各种方法去解决它，
I don't think you need to manage this alone. Major guidelines for adults with PTSD, for example, recommend trauma-focused CBD or EMDR as structured treatments for at least 8 to 12 sessions with more sometimes when needed. Like this is things that are going to help and that are prescribed. You know, if your nervous system regulation manifests as a panic disorder, the guidelines suggest sometimes up to 14 hours to be completed over four months of practical guidance with a counselor or with a therapist or maybe even a psychologist or a psychiatrist.
我觉得你不需要独自面对这一切。例如，针对患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）成人的主要指南建议，采用以创伤为中心的 CBT 或 EMDR 作为结构化治疗，疗程至少持续 8 到 12 次，有时根据需要还会更多。就像这些是会提供帮助并且是有处方依据的。你知道，如果你的神经系统调节表现为恐慌障碍，指南建议有时需要长达 14 小时，分四个月与咨询师、治疗师甚至心理学家或精神科医生一起完成实际指导。
Not everybody's going to recover in that same window, but I think it goes to show that like there are treatment plans for people. We kind of know when people will start responding, but it does really need a trained clinical professional to be able to do this safely. serious nervous system dysregulation is a condition. It doesn't affect the majority of people, but it does affect a lot of people, and that needs real clinical support. Then you can kind of add some of the other things. The second thing is to stop treating regulation as something you only do in a crisis, right? I've fallen into this trap of delaying kind of basic needs in favor
并不是每个人都会在那个时间窗口内恢复，但我认为这表明人们是有治疗方案的。我们大致知道人们什么时候会开始有反应，但这确实需要训练有素的临床专业人员才能安全地做到这一点。严重的神经系统失调是一种状况。它虽然不影响大多数人，但确实影响了很多人，这就需要真正的临床支持。然后你就可以加上其他一些事情了。第二件事是停止将调节视为只有在危机时才做的事情，对吧？在我的生活中，我很多次陷入了这样一种陷阱：为了
of productivity and output a lot of times in my life thinking that like there is things that are more important that absolutely weren't. And it's just a reminder that just because you can work harder, just because you can push yourself further, doesn't mean you should. Like, I really do think that making this part of your genuine hygiene practices of like, what am I doing today to not feel like I am always rushing or busy or stressed is an incredible thing that we should be paying attention to more? And one of the critical ways that I do that is just like giving. giving myself more time to do things, giving myself more time to get places, giving myself more time to like make errors in my progress. Do you know what I mean? Like what are simple things that you can do
追求生产力和产出而推迟了基本需求，总觉得有些事情更重要，而事实上它们绝对没有那么重要。这只是一个提醒：仅仅因为你能更努力地工作，仅仅因为你能把自己推向更远，并不意味着你就应该这样做。真的，我认为将这一点融入你真正的日常卫生习惯中——比如我今天在做什么，才不会让我觉得自己总是行色匆匆、忙碌或压力山大——这是一件我们应该更多关注的了不起的事情。我做到这一点的关键方法之一就是给予。给自己更多的时间去做事情，给自己更多的时间去赶路，给自己更多的时间在进步中犯错。你知道我的意思吗？就像你可以采取哪些简单的行动
every single day to reinsert choice and freedom and flexibility back into your life so that you are not constantly needing to rely on adrenaline and needing to rely on arousal to get things. done. Sleep hygiene, also incredible. I've spoken about sleep already quite frequently in this episode, but maybe I'm just obsessive with it at the moment. All the research says, oh, like so much of it says, if you can hack your sleep, like a lot of the other biohacking that are sold to us or that we think is required is not necessary. It is one of these functions and one of these I don't want to say resources, but one of these things if we get right, if we can figure out stems and floods into every other aspect of our life. I'll throw some data at you just to nail
每天重新将选择权、自由和灵活性融入你的生活，这样你就不会总是依赖肾上腺素和唤醒状态来完成事情。睡眠卫生也非常棒。我在本集节目中已经相当频繁地谈到睡眠了，也许我目前对此有点着迷。所有的研究都表明，哦，其中很大一部分表明，如果你能破解你的睡眠密码，那么向我们推销的或我们认为必需的许多其他生物黑客手段其实都是不必要的。这是这些功能之一，也是这些——我不想称之为资源，但如果我们将它做好，如果我们能弄清楚它，它就会渗透并流入我们生活的方方面面。我向你抛出一些数据来证实
in my point. Sleep deprivation can increase nervous system arousal by 500% across an average day. It lowers life expectancy and according to a 2000 report, the loss of one hour of sleep a night can knock a whole point off your IQ. And it's hard to have a regulated nervous system when you don't feel sharp. So if the choice is between going to a sauna for an hour or napping for an hour, take a nap.
我的观点。睡眠剥夺可以在平均一天内将神经系统唤醒度提高 500%。它会降低预期寿命，根据 2000 年的一份报告，每晚少睡一个小时会使你的智商整整下降一分。当你感觉不够敏锐时，很难让神经系统保持调节状态。因此，如果要在去桑拿一小时和小睡一小时之间做出选择，那就小睡一会儿吧。
We can also start thinking about Vegas nerve activation here, which is basically like your body's inbuilt on and off switch. The vagus nerve is one of the major, if not the most major, communication pathway between your brain and your body. It's definitely the longest, that's for sure. It's most definitely the longest, and it plays a massive role in parasympathetic control.
我们这里也可以开始考虑迷走神经激活，这基本上就像你身体内置的开关。迷走神经是你的大脑与身体之间最主要（即使不是最主要）的沟通途径之一。它绝对是最长的，那是肯定的。它绝对是最长的，并且在副交感神经控制中起着巨大的作用。
It is also the newest frontier of psychological research. There are so many therapeutic devices and interventions and methods that focus on vagus nerve activation for lessening anxiety, for lessening panic, for lessening OCD, depression, you name it. It is like, the new big thing. But you can activate the vagus nerve and its calming abilities on your own, in your room in less than five minutes. Your vagus nerve actually starts, or I guess exits your brain right below your ear. It runs the length of your neck before traveling down through the rest of your body. And the methods for stimulating it are so ancient and so simple, they almost sound useless, but literally doing things like singing, like breathing deeply, even just relaxing your
它也是心理学研究的最新前沿。有太多的治疗设备、干预措施和方法专注于迷走神经激活，以减轻焦虑、减轻恐慌、减轻强迫症、抑郁症，诸如此类。这就像是新的重大趋势。但是你完全可以靠自己，在自己的房间里，在不到五分钟的时间内激活迷走神经及其镇静功能。你的迷走神经实际上从你的耳朵正下方开始，或者说离开你的大脑。它贯穿你的整个颈部，然后向下延伸到身体的其他部位。刺激它的方法非常古老又简单，听起来几乎毫无用处，但实际上做一些事情，比如唱歌、深呼吸，甚至只是放松你的
jaw, you calm your nervous system because of that nerve pathway. Try it with me right now. Relax your jaw completely. I almost went to do it, but I have to speak, but relax your jaw completely, and then relaxed again, and then one more time, and then gently rub your neck. You're trying to relax the tension around that nerve. Do you feel better? You can even do things like sing. Literally, singing activates your vagus nerve. Like I said, this is free. Literally, everybody has this capacity.
下巴，由于那个神经通路，你就能平静你的神经系统。现在就和我一起试试。完全放松你的下巴。我刚才差点去做了，但我必须说话，不过要完全放松下巴，然后再放松一次，再来一次，然后轻轻揉揉你的脖子。你是想放松那条神经周围的紧张感。你感觉好点了吗？你甚至可以做一些像唱歌这样的事情。字面意义上，唱歌会激活你的迷走神经。就像我说的，这是免费的。字面意义上，每个人都有这种能力。
And it is pretty magnificent that your whole body feels almost at the behest of this like one nerve. It's obviously not all involved in that one long nerve. But it is critically aligned and critically related to this one nerve that you can control the tension and the pressure that your body is placing on it. Personally, I find the link between singing and Vegas nerve activation also incredibly compelling. Like, I think it's so beautiful that music is genuinely psychologically and physically healing. We think singing in the car or humming along to music whilst we cook dinner, like, even going to concerts is just like this nice, fun thing that we do. Like, it's a coincidence that we enjoy them so much. It's a coincidence that we feel better and we feel sometimes like really.
而且非常了不起的是，你的整个身体几乎都受控于这唯一的一条神经。当然，并非所有事情都与这单一的长神经有关。但它与这条神经紧密对齐且紧密相关，你可以控制身体施加在它上面的张力和压力。就个人而言，我也觉得唱歌与迷走神经激活之间的联系令人难以抗拒。我觉得音乐在心理和生理上都能真正起到治愈作用，这真是太美妙了。我们认为在车里唱歌或在做晚饭时哼唱音乐，甚至去听音乐会只是我们做的美好、有趣的事情。就像我们如此享受它们纯属巧合一样。我们感觉更好，有时感觉像真的处于一种。
high from them, but the 2010 paper found loads of evidence that music triggers calming, neurophysological, emotional and psychological reactions and acts on our body and acts on our nervous system, much like certain substances do. Like, I just wish we talked about that more, that music, people who listen to music, who sing, who engage in music more, typically have more regulated nervous systems, especially when, you know, we look at, as well, going deeper into this, like the reactions of people at concerts or fan culture or why people cry to music, why certain songs have such a fundamental impact on us. It just shows the deeply psychological influence of music
高度兴奋状态中，这纯属巧合，但 2010 年的一篇论文发现了大量证据，表明音乐会触发镇静的神经生理、情绪和心理反应，并像某些物质一样作用于我们的身体和神经系统。我只是希望我们能更多地谈论这一点：听音乐、唱歌、更多地参与音乐的人，通常拥有调节得更好的神经系统，特别是当我们更深入地探讨时，比如人们在音乐会上的反应、粉丝文化，或者为什么人们会因为音乐而哭泣，为什么某些歌曲对我们有如此根本的影响。这恰恰说明了音乐具有深刻的心理影响力
is something that isn't actually a luxury, is a necessity. Now, none of these things, including music obviously are magic switches and they mean nothing without those fundamental needs for safety and agency, but they are simple ways of offering the body repeated cues of rhythm, steadiness and safety that get us back to that homeostatic place. Your third focus area should also be slowing down how you respond to symptoms of hyper and hyper arousal though. A lot of us feel something uncomfortable and we will feel uncomfortable at times and we will still feel hyper and hyper aroused during the early stages of regulating our nervous
这不是一种奢侈品，而是一种必需品。现在，所有这些事情（显然包括音乐）都不是什么神奇的开关，如果没有对安全感和自主权的那些基本需求，它们就没有任何意义，但它们是向身体提供有关节奏、稳定性和安全的重复线索的简单方法，能让我们回到那个体内平衡的地方。你的第三个重点领域还应该是放慢你对高唤醒和低唤醒症状的反应速度。我们中的许多人感觉到不舒服时——有时我们确实会感到不舒服，并且在调节神经系统的早期阶段，我们仍然会感到高唤醒和低唤醒状态——
system and we go into fixing mode. And it's no surprise that we do that when we spent a lot of time feeling anxious or stressed or dysregulated and we're starting to improve we can feel very sensitive to the signs that it might be happening again but we have to pull back as much as we can from that there is an amazing video by somebody called maggie sterling on youtube that i would really encourage you guys to go on watch called why your nervous system won't regulate literally the easiest title ever and in it she talks about how our urgency to fix the problem of a dysregulated nervous system is actually part of the problem because it just speeds everything up when we want it to be, we want it to be slowing down to a
然后我们就会进入修复模式。当我们在焦虑、压力或失调的状态中度过了很长时间，并且开始有所改善时，我们会对可能再次发生的迹象非常敏感，我们这样做也就不足为奇了，但我们必须尽可能从那种状态中抽离出来。YouTube 上有一个叫玛吉·斯特林（Maggie Sterling）的人制作了一个精彩的视频，我真的很鼓励大家去看，标题叫做《为什么你的神经系统无法调节》（Why Your Nervous System Won't Regulate），字面意义上是有史以来最简单的标题。她在视频中谈到，我们渴望解决神经系统失调问题的迫切心情其实正是问题的一部分，因为它只会把一切都加速，而我们希望的是它能放慢到
healthy level. It makes it more of an event. When we feel anxious, we respond to it in an anxious way. So it's often, it magnifies the perceived significance of the threatening feeling. We respond to our feeling of dissociation with fear, which gives it, you know, which legitimizes the dissociation. It gives our nervous system more evidence that we absolutely do need to shut down. So what Maggie, video suggests is something highly counterintuitive, which is just to sometimes let yourself be the version of you that is dysregulated. And that sounds ridiculous given all the advice we've spoken about, but her argument is simply and essentially this. The nervous system that works best for you will be a flexible one. You cannot expect to live life without stepping outside your
健康的水平。这让它变成了一件更大的事。当我们感到焦虑时，我们以焦虑的方式作出反应。因此它往往会放大我们对威胁感受的感知重要性。我们带着恐惧去回应解离感，这就赋予了它（你知道的）合法性，即解离感。它给我们的神经系统提供了更多证据，证明我们确实需要关闭。所以玛吉视频中建议的方法非常反直觉，那就是有时只需让自己成为那个处于失调状态的你。鉴于我们讨论过的所有建议，这听起来很荒谬，但她的论据简单而本质上是这样的：
window for tolerance. Our goal is not always to live in the window, although it would be nice, it is to be able to bring ourselves back to the window when we would like to, if that makes sense. Someone who is regulated will go up and down. Somebody who is dysregulated stays in one place, and that place is not the center. Therefore, the kind of final frontier of nervous system regulation is to accept dysregulation. Let yourself feel it fully. Don't panic about it.
最适合你的神经系统将是一个灵活的神经系统。你不能指望不迈出容纳之窗就能过好生活。我们的目标并不总是停留在窗口内，尽管那样会很好，但我们的目标是当我们需要时能够把自己带回窗口内，如果这说得通的话。一个受过调节的人会有起伏。一个失调的人会停留在同一个地方，而那个地方并非中心。因此，神经系统调节的所谓最后前沿是接受失调。让自己充分感受它。不要为此惊慌失措。
literally say, this is a dysregulated response I'm having right now, isn't it? This is hyperarousal. This is hypo arousal. This is what's happening in my body. I'm going to let my nervous system do my job. And then let it take me where I need to go and I'm going to follow it. I'm not going to push myself or ask my body to go into spaces that are unnatural. I'm going to feel discomfort for a second and then I'm going to apply my methods for regulation. I'm not going to speed everything up or slow everything down. Again, that may feel quite counterintuitive, and it's a weird way to end the episode. Is the secret to being regulated, being dysregulated? Seems like a trick. But I think it makes more sense in the context of nervous system regulation becoming more popular. Again, we accidentally
字面意义上说：我现在有这种失调的反应，对吧？这是高唤醒。这是低唤醒。这就是我身体里正在发生的事情。我要让我的神经系统做它的工作。然后让它带我去我需要去的地方，我会顺其自然。我不会强求自己或要求身体进入不自然的狭小空间。我会感受一秒钟的不适，然后应用我的调节方法。我不会让一切加速或减慢。再次说明，这可能会让人觉得相当反直觉，而且这是结束本集的一个奇怪方式。难道被调节的秘诀就是失调吗？这听起来像是个圈套。但我认为在神经系统调节变得越来越流行的背景下，这更有意义。我们再次不经意地
make the nervous system sound like it's our enemy. And so anything that doesn't feel calm feels wrong. Anything that is fight or flight, like that's bad. Stress is bad. Cortisol is bad. You know, if we're in an activated or aroused state, something has gone wrong. If you or somebody like me thinking that means that when it naturally does go wrong, which it will, it's not that it's going wrong that's bad. It's our exaggerated response to that because we are afraid of it getting worse. Your stress response is not a design flaw. It is protective. It wants to keep us alive. So rather than vilifying our nervous system and being fearful or panicked by the setting it operates on at times, it may be more compassionate and perhaps more sustainable and effective
把神经系统说成是我们的敌人。因此，任何感觉不平静的事情都感觉是错的。任何属于战斗或逃跑的东西，那都是不好的。压力是不好的。皮质醇是不好的。你知道，如果我们处于激活或唤醒状态，那就是出了问题。如果你或像我这样的人认为这意味着当它自然出问题时（它确实会），不好的并不是它出了问题，而是我们对它的过度反应，因为我们害怕情况会变得更糟。你的应激反应并不是设计缺陷。它是具有保护性的。它想让我们保持存活。因此，与其妖魔化我们的神经系统，并对它运作时的设置感到恐惧或惊慌，不如更有同情心，也许更具可持续性和有效性
to have that psychoeducation to reapply the logic and say, this is my body, it's working very hard to keep me safe, thank you for doing that. And I'm not always going to feel great. I'm not always going to feel good about it. You know, I'm not always going to feel regulated and that's okay. The flexibility is what I'm after. I also think, let's say it again, the second biggest thing I hope you got out of this episode is that a regulated nervous system is not something that you can buy. I was looking up when I was researching this episode, all the different methods for, you know, Vegas nerve activation and regulation and calming. I found a device that was like, like somebody had priced at like 2,000, 3,000 pounds or $3,000.
进行这种心理教育，重新应用逻辑并说：这是我的身体，它为了保证我的安全一直在努力工作，谢谢你这么做。而且我不可能永远都感觉良好。我不可能永远对此感觉良好。你知道，我不可能永远都处于被调节的状态，这没关系。灵活性才是我所追求的。我还认为，再说一次，我希望你从本集节目中获得的第二大收获是：一个受过调节的神经系统并不是你用钱能买到的。我在研究本集节目时，查阅了各种用于迷走神经激活、调节和平静的方法。我发现了一个设备，有人给它标价大概 2,000、3,000 英镑或 3,000 美元。
And I think what I was intending to do with this episode is make you realize, like, you don't need that. I think maybe 1% of people who are struggling with this need that. You don't need a device that tracks your sleep. You don't need a $3,000 backyard. Saw and I'm sure they cost a lot more. When you have all this stuff within you, that is free, that is accessible, that can help you more than a gadget.
我想我这集节目的本意是让你意识到，你根本不需要那个。我想也许只有 1% 苦于此道的人才需要那个。你不需要一个追踪你睡眠的设备。你不需要一个价值 3,000 美元的后院桑拿房——我确信它们的花费要高得多。当你拥有这一切都在你体内时，它是免费的，触手可及的，它比任何小玩意儿都能更多地帮助你。
Now, something that is expensive that is worth it is therapy and is getting like a genuine help. Let us like dig into your past and like really pick up the threads of where this dysregulation has happened. But only when you have those base, like the baseline, basic needs available to you, choice that is available to you, social help and assistance and support, do we add those things on the top. So I hope this episode has been helpful. I hope that it's taught you more about the fundamentals of nervous system regulation. Again, this is just a basic introductory episode. I'm going to leave some more stuff down below from people who spend so much more time thinking about this and talking about this than I do. And I hope the value of science and the
现在，有些昂贵但确实值得的东西就是心理治疗，也就是获得真正的帮助。让我们深入了解你的过去，真正找出这种失调发生时的种种线索。但是，只有当你拥有了这些基础的保障——比如基准的基本需求、可用的选择、社会的帮助、援助和支持——我们才会把这些东西叠加在上面。所以，我希望这期节目对你有所帮助。我希望它能让你更多地了解神经系统调节的基础知识。再次重申，这只是一个基础的入门节目。我会在下方分享更多内容，来自那些花比我多得多的时间来思考和谈论这个话题的人。我希望科学的价值以及其背后的科学依据能够触动你，让你相信这是重要的，同时也让你意识到你在网上听到的一些事情可能并不是真的。如果你喜欢这期节目，只需提醒一下，你现在可以在Netflix上收听——哦，我应该说观看——本播客《你二十岁的心理学》的完整单集。如果你想阅读本节目文稿，并在Substack上获取我提到的一些研究链接，你也可以阅读文稿。如果你对此有更多有趣的看法或你自己的经历，你可以在Instagram上私信我，账号是That Psychology Podcast，
scientific backing to this has kind of reached you and convinced you that this is important, but also made you realize some of the things that you hear online might not be true. If you've enjoyed this episode, just a reminder that you can now listen, oh, I should say watch full episodes of this podcast, The Psychology of Your 20s on Netflix. You can also read the transcript to this episode if you want some of the links to the research I mentioned on Substack. And if you have further interesting thoughts about this or your own experiences, you can DM me at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram,
或者你可以在下方Spotify的评论区留言。我希望这真的对你来说是一期很棒的入门节目。如果你正在经历或思考神经系统调节这件事，我希望它能重塑你的一些信念和期望。我希望它是informative（富有成效）的。我觉得这句话我已经说过一百万遍了，但我希望，是的，它确实很有启发性，教给了你一些东西。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员莉比·科布（Libby Cobb）对本节目的协助。
or you can leave a comment on Spotify below. I hope this really was a great introductory episode for you. I hope that it's reset some of your beliefs and expectations about nervous system regulation if it is something that you are encountering or thinking about yourself. And I hope it's been informative. I feel like I've said that a million times, but I hope, yeah, that it's been informative and taught you something. Thank you as always to our researcher Libby Cobb for her assistance with this episode.
我们下期再见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。嗨，波特兰迷们。我是凯莉·布朗斯坦（Carrie Brownstein）和弗雷德·阿米森（Fred Armisen）。90年代的梦想在播客形式中依然活着。我们正在推出《Podlandia，A.O.重温》（Podlandia, A.O. Rewatch），这是我们的全新播客，我们将在这里一起重温《波特兰迪亚》（Portlandia）的每一集，剖析各种小品，深入探讨我们标志性的角色，并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后花絮。我们还将邀请那些帮助将这一切变为现实的人加入我们，包括特邀明星、
And until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, A.O. Rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life, guest stars,
合作者和朋友，包括导演乔纳森·克里萨尔（Jonathan Chrysall）、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦（Kyle MacLachlan）、传奇音乐家艾米·曼（Amy Mann）等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有关于它的歌曲。嗯，我以为你们所有人都要写首歌。我记得你是这么想的。收听在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方播出的《Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch》。
collaborators and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song about it. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
嘿，我是海斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。还有肖恩·克莱门茨（Sean Clements）。我们主持播客《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）。每一集我们都在试图帮助我们的嘉宾改善他们的职业生涯，主要是通过关注他们如何能帮助我们改善职业生涯。这个节目以超级平易近人而闻名，所以你可以轻松地跳进我们650集中的任何一集并听懂发生了什么。我们推荐一些我们最近的节目，嘉宾包括本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller）、丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride）、里兹·阿迈德（Riz Ahmed）和玛丽·斯汀伯根（Mary Steenburgen）。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。在《独行女子》（Solita）中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的混乱现实。
Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our guests improve their careers by mainly focusing on how they can help us improve our careers. The show's famously super accessible so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes and understand what's going on. We recommend some of our recent episodes with Ben Stiller, Danny McBride, Riz Ahmed, and Mary Steenberg. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman.
当你体内有一个男人时，你的多邻国是不会帮你的。哦，不。我是朱莉·皮内罗（Julie Pinero），我独自旅行，因为这是一个难得的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就能说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代同情。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。我是尼克·蒂托罗（Nick Turturro）。你大概在《纽约重案组》（NYPD Blue）、《最长的一码》（The Longest Yard）或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》（BlacKkKlansman）中认识我。
Your duolingo is not going to come back to you when a man is inside of you. Oh, no. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nick Titoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard. or Spike Lee's Black Klansman.
在我的新播客《尼克·托图罗带你收获幸福》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Turturro）中，我给一位新嘉宾送披萨。我和每个人分享一块披萨，从赛斯·罗林斯（Seth Rollins）——你在干什么，我的腰带？——到比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr）。我觉得我从来没有遇到过哪个人的精神状态像我一样如此异于常人。
And on my new podcast, Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro, I deliver pizza to a new guest. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing, my belt? To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am.
现在，我们还将迎来更多伟大的嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·托图罗（John Turturro）。它叫“幸福”，传递幸福。还有很多很多。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Delivering Happiness with Nick Turturro》。立即收听。这是来自《亲爱的切尔西》（Dear Chelsea）的切尔西·汉德勒（Chelsea Handler）。
And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness, Delivering Happiness. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Tutro. And listen now. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea.
每周，新闻都在变糟。世界变得越来越疯狂。亚曼妮卡（Yamanika）在这里告诉任何应该负责的人，你才是问题所在。你知道我刚发现西德尼·斯威尼（Sidney Sweeney）是谁吗？如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。做得更好，或者少做一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。我是亚曼妮卡，我先走一步。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客上收听亚曼妮卡的《You're the Problem》，
Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less so I don't have to do so much. I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to You're the Problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast,
或在你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个iHeart播客，保证是真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast Guaranteed Human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。